we know working together can be hard you
guys but do you really have to make it
awkward for the rest of the cast so you
don't like each other big what you guys
are actors so just pretend like you do
co-starring in a Disney Channel TV
series with someone you can't stand
probably isn't easy but hey most of you
managed to pull it off cuz we literally
had no idea you were feuding in the
first place move in with me
we're like sisters it'll be fun y'all
you won't believe how many Disney
Channel stars couldn't stand working
together we thought they were BFFs only
to find out that they were worst enemies
keep watching to find out which Girl
Meets World co-stars don't talk to each
other anymore debby ryan and sky jackson
debby ryan and sky jackson met on the
set of jessie back in 2011 and at first
they seemed to be rather close Skye was
even reported giving Debbie praise
saying that she was a great person with
good acting skills
Debbie Ryan is fantastic I love to have
her but in 2015
rumors of Debbie bullying Skye on the
set of their show started circulating
and Debbie responded to the rumors by
saying that if she was 12 she probably
would be insecure about the lead of the
show she was supporting on - after some
shade got thrown back and forth Skye
took things a step further by
unfollowing Debbie on Twitter zendaya
coleman and bella thorne
sindhya and Bella co-starred in the
Disney Channel show shake it up and
their relationship was shaky to say the
least
how are you always late give me a break
the girls were often pinned against each
other making it look like they couldn't
stand one another but Bella eventually
came clean about their feud in an
interview with j-14 according to Bella
she and zendaya were often placed in
situations where they had to compete
against each other which made season one
of shake it up super awkward
but all that's in the past now and
zendaya and Bella are great friends
dylan sprouse and Joe Jonas
although dylan sprouse and Joe Jonas
weren't exactly co-stars they were part
of the Disney Channel family and back
when The Suite Life of Zack and Cody and
Jonas were two of the most popular
Disney sitcoms ever I of the tiger
Dylan and Joe bumped heads online it all
started when Joe wrote an essay saying
that he felt trapped as a huge Disney
star and was having trouble being the
perfect doll Disney wanted him to be and
Dylan clapped back by saying that Joe's
essay was nonsense because everyone has
the right to say no Miley Cyrus and
Emily Osment Miley Cyrus and Emily
Osment were total BFFs on the set of
Hannah Montana but that just wasn't the
case when the cameras weren't rolling
despite wanting to be as close family as
Hannah was to Lilly I'm sorry what being
the best friend I've ever had
Miley reported feeling disappointed over
their friendship or lack of friendship
that is in the end Miley and Emily just
couldn't figure out how to get along
you're just bitter cuz your dresser
doesn't love you
Drake Bell and Josh Peck Drake and Josh
aren't known for being Nickelodeon and
Disney stars who came up together on the
set of Drake and Josh they spent years
by each other's sides and were seen as
two peas in a pod dude but there was
trouble in paradise
their feud only grew when Josh got
married and didn't invite Drake to his
wedding but Josh figured it wasn't a big
deal since they hardly ever talked
anymore the two friends have worked
things out since the incident but their
friendship isn't what it used to be
Selena Gomez and Jake T Austin Selena
and Jake were cast as siblings on the
hit Disney sitcom Wizards of Waverly
Place and like most siblings they didn't
really get along I am switching sides
although they managed to work things out
their friendship took a hit when Jake
blasted Selena for taking on more adult
roles and leaving her young fan base
behind Selena fans were quick to tell
Jake to mind his own business the
Sprouse twins and Selena Gomez it looks
like we have some repeat offenders
because dylan sprouse and Selena Gomez
are back at it again but this time Cole
was there to back his twin-brother
up as it turns out the Sprouse twins
were upset with Selena because she
wouldn't follow them on social media and
acted like she was too good for them
Dillon tweeted about this but Selena
never answered back proving that the
Sprouse twins might be on to something
certainly makes ashley tisdale and Lucas
Grabeel Ashley and Lucas were cast as
the Evans siblings in the High School
Musical franchise but unlike their
on-screen characters they weren't
exactly friendly we hated each other
they couldn't wait to wrap up production
to get away from each other but it turns
out that working together might have
been the issue because ever since HSM 3
wrapped they becomes the best of friends
Raven and the Cheetah Girls the Cheetah
Girls franchise was the cream of the
crop back in the early 2000s but as it
turns out there was some tension between
Raven and the rest of the band members
so much so that reason didn't appear in
the three quilt choosing to pursue the
movie College Road Trip instead but now
that the past is in the past Raven and
Adrien have reconciled their friendship
I climb on top of this girl and gave her
the Rowan Blanchard and Uriah Shelton
these Girl Meets World co-stars just
couldn't see eye to eye
their feud caused risks between the cast
and Rowan and Uriah haven't talked since
the Disney show was canceled back in
2017 time and distance have no power
over us their feud began due to uriah
liking anti-feminist posts on Instagram
and it only escalated from there which
one of these Disney feuds did you find
most shocking tell us in the comments
for more fun videos about your favorite
Disney Channel stars subscribe to the
things and be sure to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching we'll
see you next time
[Music]